DAN GALPIN: We've now
reached the second release
of the Android Q beta program.
Q has enhancements to privacy
and security, and, of course,
there's a lot of great
stuff for developers.
Let's start with how Q builds on
top of Android's strong privacy
protections.
Android Q enhances runtime
permission requests
to give users more control over
when apps can get location.
When Android Q prompts users
to give the app the location
permission, it now enables users
to allow the permission only
while the app is in
use in the foreground,
allow the permission always,
or to deny the permission.
Check out the developer
guide for details
on how to adapt your app for
this new permission model.
Android Q continues the
work in previous releases
to limit access to
non-resettable device
identifiers including device
IMEI and serial number.
The Mac address to
the device is now
randomized by default
when connected
to different Wi-Fi networks.
Most of our APIs for
scanning networks
already require the course
location permission,
but in Android Q for
Bluetooth, cellular, and Wi-Fi,
we're increasing the
protection around those APIs
by requiring the fine
location permission instead.
Finally, Android Q continues
the process of limiting access
to non-SDK internal interfaces.
You can turn on and off
this for testing purposes
and tell Android to enable
access but print log messages.
Android Q adds new support
for foldable devices,
allowing multiple apps to
be in this resumed state
at the same time.
Most apps won't have
to address this change,
but we've added a
top resumed activity
callback that should be
used to open and close
exclusive devices
such as the camera.
We've also changed how the
re-sizable activity manifest
attribute works.
In Q, if an app sets re-sizable
activity equals false along
with a fixed orientation
or aspect ratio,
display changes
will cause the app
to be letterboxed and resized
to maintain the aspect ratio.
You can use the canary
release of Android Studio 3.5
to create a foldable virtual
device with a beta 2 image.
The emulator gives
you onscreen controls
to trigger fold, unfold, change
orientation, and quick actions.
Also an Android Q,
apps can request
a dynamic in depth image.
Supported device cells
will return a JPEG
with embedded XMP
metadata related
to depth-related elements and
a depth in competence map.
The existing direct share
feature gives users the power
to share content to a specific
contact with another app,
but the implementation
adds latency
when displaying the share UI.
In Android Q, developers
can publish share targets
in advance, allowing the share
UI to load much more quickly.
These works similarly
to app shortcuts,
so we've expanded
their shortcut info
API to make integrating
both features easier
and added the share
target AndroidX library
to allow apps to leverage
the new functionality
while still supporting pre-Q
devices using direct share.
Android Q ads platform support
for notification bubbles,
circular icons that
represent app content.
Various apps have used
system alert windows
to build similar
interactions, and we're
excited to standardize on a
straightforward implementation
for developers that provides
consistent interactions
for users.
Bubbles are built on top of
Android's notification system
to provide a familiar and easy
to use APIs for developers
with a bubble being a
type of notification.
To bubble a
notification, you need
to make sure the notification
channel allows bubble
notifications and then call
set bubble metadata to add
bubble metadata.
Within the metadata, you
provide the bubble icon
along with the activity to
display as bubble content.
In Q, you can use the
settings panel API
to show key system settings
as a floating panel
in the context of your app.
A browser could use
this API to display
connectivity settings such
as airplane mode, Wi-Fi,
and mobile data.
Users can then
manage these settings
without leaving the app.
We've done a bunch in Android Q
to allow for higher performance
apps.
For example, apps can
create a Wi-Fi lock
to ask the platform to optimize
Wi-Fi around low latency.
Android Q also adds support
for the high performance Vulkan
1.1 graphics API and
makes 1.1 a requirement
for all 64-bit devices
running Q and higher.
Android Q contains a preview
of a standard updatable OpenGL
driver for all devices built
on Vulkan called Angle.
You can enable
Angle for all apps
or for individual apps
in developer options.
The neural networks API has
been updated to version 1.2,
adding 60 new opps
including arg max,
arg min, quantized LSTM, laying
the foundation for accelerating
a wider range of
models such as those
for object detection
and image segmentation.
Android Q now allows apps to
pull the current thermal status
of the device and
register for a callback
when the thermal status changes.
This can help real-time
applications such as games,
reduce their
workload in response
to an overheating device.
We've also added a native
MIDI API in the NDK.
This API allows MIDI
data to be retrieved
inside an audio callback using
a non-blocking thread, enabling
low latency processing
of MIDI messages.
Google Play is now delivering
cloud-based profiles along
with APKs.
These are anonymized
aggregate art profiles
that let art pre-compile
parts of your app
even before it's run, giving
a significant jumpstart
to the overall
optimization process.
Cloud-based profiles
benefit all apps,
and they're already available
to devices running Android P
and higher.
And there's so much more like
support for the AV1 video
codec, improvements for
managing IoT devices over Wi-Fi,
passive support for biometric
prompt, and TLS 1.3.
For information on how to
install the Android Q beta,
check out the links
in the description.
Enjoy Android Q. Learn about
the new features and APIs
you can using your apps.
Please leave us
feedback on the beta.
On the Android Q
beta developer site,
you'll find release notes
and support resources
for reporting issues.